let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
loud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
the Corvette has entered the chat
[Music]
oh they're gonna be pissed
[ __ ] right Wingers are gonna be
pissed they're gonna be absolute losing
their minds on the interwebs today it's
gonna be all about Corbett
and it's at his home in Wilmington
Delaware I got it the former vice
president had access
if you're classified documents and he
had a couple of them
in a locked garage
with his Corvette of all things you
bastard
listen don't be scared of this story
okay
I I believe that this is all going to
actually shake out in um not
Trump's favor listen
folks
the documents that Joe Biden has
was not stolen from the government to
try to cover up a [ __ ] coup
I don't know how much further you got to
go than that
of the difference between why it is
[ __ ] criminal for Donald Trump to
steal our [ __ ] top secret documents
and documents in general to cover up a
[ __ ] coup attempt
sell them whatever the [ __ ] he was doing
with them destroying them
and then obstructing justice when they
said hey we need those back
and Joe Biden having a few documents
more than likely to recount for memoirs
an accidental pile of documents that had
classified markings
it's the other thing you have to be very
clear here that these documents that are
that were in his Wilmington home had
markings
and because they found some in the
closet they did a full review they
didn't wait for a full year wait for the
FBI to release a [ __ ] warrant to come
search your residence because you're
obstructing documents that they know you
have
this is really [ __ ] stupid and by the
way again the media fails here every
single [ __ ] time why is this bad for
Joe Biden and great for Trump
it's not it's not bad for Joe Biden and
it's horrible for Trump
to be quite honest
the reason why is because when the
investigators who investigating the
investigators of the investigators who
investigate and the other investigators
get a hold of this and they present the
evidence to the American people you will
find Joe Biden the former vice president
the present currently he's currently the
president who handles top secret
information all day long
was following protocols when they found
that he accidentally had this in his
office and in his garage
by his Corvette of all things I think
that's a beautiful part of the story
it's a beautiful part of the story
a lot of people are going to act like
that's a bad thing
no no that's a great thing
how do you think Joe Biden won this
election
Joe Biden pulled a lot of white males
over to his side during 2020. one of it
one of the ways he did that
was appearing in ads with [ __ ]
aviators in the goddamn Corvette you
think Donald Trump for one [ __ ]
minute could drive a Corvette no [ __ ]
him he wouldn't even know how to sit his
fat ass in a [ __ ] Corvette let alone
drive one of those [ __ ]
he ain't no common man you remember when
he got up into the [ __ ] fire truck
he act like he never had his hands on
the steering wheel in his entire [ __ ]
life because he hadn't
always being toting around and [ __ ]
limousine and helicopters and private
jets [ __ ] him
man of the people my [ __ ] ass
Joe Biden having having his stuff in his
locked garage with his Corvette
his prized possession
not a jet
not a [ __ ] building in New York
not a [ __ ] golf course and a mansion
not some Tower he wants to build in
Russia no it's a Corvette every [ __ ]
American middle class dream to have a
car or a toy
that you want
whatever it may be doesn't have to
actually be a car
a dream
a dream
oh they're gonna lose the plot folks
they already have but it's up to you it
is up to you to not believe the nonsense
and the [ __ ] of the [ __ ] media
especially this [ __ ] juicy [ __ ]
why would you do that why would you have
why would you have documents
in your garage next to your Corvette Mr
President
again
and again and again and again you have
to say and I'll say it
these documents were not taken and
stolen from the United States government
an attempt to cover up a [ __ ] coup
attempt it was not stolen from the
government to cover up obstruction and
collusion with Russia in 2016. you
goddamn right I'm accusing Trump of that
he stole [ __ ] documents that has his
[ __ ] name on him that show
Intelligence of him colluding with
[ __ ] Russia in 2016. you goddamn
right
prove me [ __ ] wrong
do it
let's do it
and an apartment of justice is reviewing
every single document that Biden had
anyways with a [ __ ] Trump appointed
United States Attorney so get the [ __ ]
over it and they filed protocol from the
moment they knew they had that he
possibly had these documents you dumb
bucks
so let them get mad get him mad get him
pissed off I'm telling you you want to
[ __ ] poke the bear on this one
this story of the Biden documents is
really bad for Trump
not for Biden
I know it's going to be like oh I don't
want to talk about this because you know
for for for weeks Tony I've been talking
about Trump and now here's Biden with
these documents look a lot of government
officials have classified documents I
don't know if you remember the story
of a general famous General
he was writing a book
uh the author he was having an affair
with her
and he happened to lead classified
documents in her possession
which is not protocol it's not protocol
for classified documents for someone who
knows they have those documents to leave
them in The Possession
of someone who does not have the
authority
to possess those documents there's
protocols around these things
Trump was not following protocols Not
only was he not following protocols that
that Nara set for him
he was lying he was obstructing and this
is why this is why it's different too
not just because he [ __ ] stole those
documents to cover up a coup attempt
but because he is a known liar he's a
known [ __ ] criminal listen any
average old day not one of these
[ __ ] that were in the Trump
Administration especially the ones with
the last name Trump
would get a [ __ ] security clearance
to even dream of being in the same room
as these [ __ ] documents
we would not trust our national security
secrets
with the trumps unless he won on a
technicality in 2016 where he colluded
with Russia to win
that's the only way and that's the only
way it happened so anyway he had access
to him
and again if you think that the special
counsel's case is about about a bunch of
classified documents that he had in his
home at Mar-A-Lago you're missing the
[ __ ] Target
those [ __ ] documents down at
Mar-A-Lago are only evidence
of the cover-up of the Cheeto dust
kangaroo coup attempt
this [ __ ] lie that they think the
election was stolen that is all a bunch
of [ __ ]
he didn't believe that garbage I mean he
may now he's he's hopped up on Q and on
like a [ __ ] so he may have
finally bought into it
but during the January 6 Insurrection
when they tried to overthrow our vote
and take away our government make him
the dictator and the king and [ __ ] on
our constitution
him his allies his lawyers his legal
counsel in the White House
[ __ ] members of Congress in the
senate members of state legislators
they were all colluding to [ __ ] have
a coup
and he stole documents from us to cover
that [ __ ] up
that [ __ ] documents case of
Mar-A-Lago ain't got a goddamn thing to
do with classified or Declassified not a
[ __ ] thing
it has to do with obstructing the
investigation of us getting to the
bottom of why and when and how they
tried to overturn our [ __ ] democracy
those [ __ ] documents sitting next to
Joe Biden's Corvette ain't got a goddamn
thing to do with a coup you stupid [ __ ]
so good luck to the moglodytes good luck
to the trumpers good luck to the America
First Nazi party and good luck to
Marjorie Taylor green you [ __ ] [ __ ]
with your stupid narrative that the vice
president doesn't have the power to
declassify documents yeah again we're
back to the Mind Trick [ __ ]
we're back to the Mind Trick stuff and
the reason why I don't get caught in
that [ __ ] and the reason why is
because no president has the ability to
declassify [ __ ] documents with their
mind and if they do Joe Biden is the
president so he done did it you stupid
[ __ ]
what a dumbass argument for this [ __ ]
stupid troglodyte to make
I'm gonna show you the [ __ ] tweet
today I'm gonna show it to you Marjorie
Taylor green her dumbass the the [ __ ]
quasi-speaker of the house Marjorie
Taylor green that's right Kevin she owns
your [ __ ] balls
not to mention
not to mention the economic news in this
country where inflation is actually I
don't know going down
it's going in the correct direction
because the guy who doesn't have
documents to [ __ ] cover up a coup
is doing right by the country and the
American people
because he gives a [ __ ] about him
hey you know just a little
it doesn't take a lot for a person to
give a [ __ ] about the American people to
do some of the right things
Donald Trump never did never will never
can he can't
and gutless [ __ ] coward did you see
the video he put out yesterday oh my God
he is terrified not only not only have
they lost the plot here on this
documents thing because boy that is the
battle they wanted to wage they do not
want to wage the battle with January 6.
they want to Wade in this documents
thing now especially now that it's it's
known that Joe Biden looked at
classified documents and had possession
of him he had a security clearance for
those classifications
laughs
Jesus Christ and they followed protocol
the moment they found them they didn't
lie about it they didn't try to cover it
up they didn't try to [ __ ] destroy
him or sell them or whatever you were
trying to do you fat turd
but it is such a stark difference
to watch a former failing president the
biggest [ __ ] loser of all time
flail about
about his narrative
that oh I didn't steal documents and try
to cover up a coup
it was stolen for me
and here the president of the United
States is
openly saying yep yesterday they found
them they're in my garage next to my vet
we hand him over immediately Department
Justice is going to figure out where
they were why they were there all that
kind of good stuff there's plenty of
explanation there's a reason why they
were there
and there's a handful of them that have
classified markings
and he had proper attorneys go through
this stuff what I mean by that is people
who aren't going to lose their [ __ ]
law license
about lying about this [ __ ]
that continues to be a pattern in the
Trump orb
yeah
again back to the good economic news
and gas prices continue to go down
as the Biden Administration implements
their plan
to lower the cost of fuel exploring the
cost
of just about everything in the country
grocery prices still stagnant Foods
price is still stagnant because of eggs
but these things happen in the economy
we'll get past it
remember when they said that if Joe
Biden was elected gas would be ten
dollars a gallon and the stock market
would crash you remember that
yeah they're full of [ __ ] so don't
believe a goddamn thing and no thread or
no [ __ ] links they send you or any of
this [ __ ]
about these documents that the president
of the United States has already turned
over
our current President Joe Biden a
legitimate president who won
legitimately
who didn't try to use these classified
documents
and attempt to cover up a [ __ ] coup
[ __ ] boneheads and Jim Jordan I think
this morning is already declared
oh now we're yeah oh boy oh buddy now
it's on like Donkey Kong let's do it Jim
I don't report sex crimes Jordan I dare
you you [ __ ] I dare you oh I
dare him
media again is getting this all wrong
though
so if you're if you're watching the
media and you're watching this document
story and it's making you feel like oh
my God almost turn it off turn that [ __ ]
off
media does not know what they're doing
at all
now the right-wing meeting knows exactly
what they're doing oh baby yeah you
[ __ ] ain't right the right wing media
knows exactly what they're doing they're
going to spend this the way they need to
spend it and present this to mind [ __ ]
Their audience
oh it's the exact same thing and they're
coming after Trump oh Trump is so
oppressed that's what he said in his
video
they're coming after you American people
and
more than anyone me oh so that me
him and himself Jesus Christ
can you imagine being so obsessed with
someone who's so obsessed with
themselves good Lord
he's got enough obsession with himself
for enough you don't need anyone else
really
how there's millions of people that
are completely tied to this idiot I
don't know I guess that's just how Cults
work
maybe I should have a cult expert on and
explain this [ __ ] to me I can't figure
it out
I mean I get the whole drama thing right
we talk about WrestleMania real life
here
right
we talk about this [ __ ] where they're
making our [ __ ] government and our
[ __ ] democracy into some kind of
reality TV dumpster fire right
I mean I I kind of understand that but
God damn
to absolutely suck at that fat turd's
teat
especially after that deranged shitty
diaper rant that he had yesterday oh my
God
you're never you're listen to me listen
to me I'm sure of this you will never
ever ever see some [ __ ]
dumbass produced video for Joe Biden to
go on and explain why he committed crime
and why it's okay that he committed
crime and why the Matrix is coming after
him because he because he committed
crime
tough [ __ ]
homeboy tough [ __ ] [ __ ] you did
it you tried to overthrow our government
you tried it every single pass any
chance you had to [ __ ] subvert our
democracy and obstruct our vote
and to become the dictator and King and
[ __ ] on our Constitution and not follow
your oath
and every pass every turn you tried
and it wasn't just you you had thousands
helping you thousands I'm telling you
when we get over this in history
the one thing that's going to be
astounding I mean just
[ __ ] I'm our our [ __ ] children and
grandchildren will be stand back in awe
of how many people went to prison for
Trump and his presidency
there it is going to be something
that we are going to talk about for
decades and decades and decades in this
country
how many people went to prison for this
dumb [ __ ]
buffoon
but it's reality
to where we're at we're gonna have
members of Congress wrapped up possibly
members of the Senate state legislators
the Attorney General in Michigan has
already said and she's screaming she's
jumping up and down waving her hands
like hey hey there's State Electric
crime there's federal crime right here
I'm pointing it out giving referrals
hello hello
anybody there doj they're there
I don't know if you saw this but Jack
Smith is issuing more subpoenas
and it's not good for Trump
not good for Trump
they're getting down to the skinny here
I believe they're trying to figure out
exactly who's going to [ __ ] be an
asset in this investigation and flip
and who's who's ultimately going to be
targets other than Trump probably
Jeffrey Clark and a few others
John Eastman another Target now they've
subpoenaed Rudy Giuliani apparently uh
this Super Pac and this defense fund oh
[ __ ] let me tell you something
you dumb [ __ ] that were out
there raising money for this idiot
defrauding his supporters
Financial crimes are not [ __ ] that the
federal government [ __ ] around with
and this is this is well well
Beyond a document's case
or even a even a [ __ ] violent
Insurrection case
I mean this guy's climbing all the time
he never stops
and it's never just one crime he's never
just doing one crime
he's got mountains
mountains of [ __ ] crime
I mean he doesn't like his crimes to be
alone he didn't like him to be lonely he
wants to have a group of crimes
so to actually think or believe that
because the former vice president the
current president of the United States
had a few documents locked in a secure
closet and in a garage next to his
Corvette
are are somehow
have the same Equity as Donald Trump the
former president United States
dealing without the proper protocol
of our [ __ ] documents so that he can
cover up his attempt to overthrow our
constitution
and Crown himself King
destroying them hiding them obstructing
the Nara and the Department of Justice
of getting their document our documents
back
as if it's the same thing
if you believe that I got a [ __ ] I
got oceanfront property in Arizona I'd
love to sell you
you are a dumb [ __ ] holy [ __ ] I
bet I could sell you a thousand t-shirts
speaking of that
if you wanna
great t-shirt and go to
store.dtonymichaels.com why not if
you're listening right now you might as
well man go to the store.d Tony
michaels.com get your dark Brandon
shirts you're gonna need them dark
Brandon maybe we should do a a documents
Brandon
I'm just saying
I'm just saying uh anyone out there who
is scared of this narrative that Joe
Biden had a few classified documents
you're not doing this correctly I'm
telling you this is going to be horrible
for Trump it's going to be horrible for
the Republicans the truth always is
the truth always is bad for them
so don't be scared of it don't be scared
of the truth they're the ones terrified
of it lean into it [ __ ] them
[ __ ] em
their guys stole our documents harbored
them obstructed that the Department of
Justice getting them back so that he
could cover up his attempt to overthrow
our constitution
Joe Biden did not
that's the [ __ ] difference
that's the difference folks and that's
why you come listen to the Tony Michaels
podcast every single weekday Monday
through Friday noon Eastern 11 Central 9
Pacific on YouTube Twitter and twitch
damn
you guys really leaned into this 20 000
thing yesterday make sure we're gonna
try to get to 20 000 before the end of
the month I don't know maybe I'll do
something special
what do you think we do like a special
episode or something if we reach 20 000
like we do a special 20 000 episode or
some [ __ ] like that I don't know maybe
we make it private or something I don't
know what we'll do you guys start
getting in the chat with the ideas the
mods will pick up on it they'll let me
know what you guys are saying what you
guys want
to do to celebrate twenty thousand Subs
now we're over thirteen thousand now
let's get to twenty because it's been
two years of Tony that's what we're
calling it here two years of Tony on
January 14th
2021 the day that Donald Trump got
impeached on the house floor I went live
so it's been two full years
in two days since I went live so I don't
know if that makes tomorrow do your
anniversary or Monday I'm not really
sure I think Monday
that may Monday I mean it'd be the 16th
that's I mean officially Saturday but
and we're not live on the air on
Saturday
it's not how it works here at the Tony
Michaels podcast we're live every single
weekday for two full hours Monday
through Friday
on YouTube Twitter and twitch and
simulcasting from the Midas touch
Facebook page and if you're on Facebook
go follow us on Facebook and then come
over to YouTube
And subscribe if you're whatever
platform you're on right now we're
trying to get the 20 000 subscribers
on YouTube
and we're so close also download every
single episode help us out go to your
favorite directory download the episodes
listen to them re-listen to them you
know
at least the first 30 minutes you hear
me yelling and screaming getting the
narrative for the day the messaging for
the day and the message today
that I want you to take with you is the
former president United States to cheat
on us cue in honor
he stole thousands of our classified
documents to cover up his coup attempt
not to hold them next to his beautiful
beautiful Corvette everyone stick around
we'll be right back
right after this break
we'll be right back
Mark 60 seconds this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard and blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardon's not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
of the show
got a lot of video to show you today we
got the um you got the daily video
George Santos High jailing into the
elevator no that [ __ ] is all or
no bite if he was having a little bit of
a back and forth on Twitter with Adam
kinsinger of course you know how I feel
about Adam kinzinger but they were
having a little back and forth on the
twit machine
and he was being a smart ass
this morning though
he mentioned as he was racing to the
elevator because he's got a race there
because they can't get on the elevator
with him
it's only in reserved for members of
Congress so they can't get on those
elevators so they can only question him
until he gets there so he's like
out of his office into the [ __ ]
Elevator Hurry Hurry
just be lying of course the reporters
are there and question and he may have
yelled something out of the elevator as
the doors were closing we'll watch the
video today to confirm this but I think
he said if 142 people ask for me to
resign then he'll do it now I I don't
know if he just means like 142 people in
general if that's the case that
[ __ ] should already resigned
weeks ago and again I keep telling you I
don't want George Santos to resign I
Tony Michaels does not want George
Santos to resign one reason why is
because I want the daily Chase video
I want to watch this daily [ __ ]
exercise where this feeble Little Liar
this [ __ ] fraud
has to dodge people asking him questions
about the truth
and really frankly you know George
Santos again I've said is no standout
from any other Republican
he doesn't tell any special lies he just
tells all of them
what do I mean well
most Republicans pick one or two maybe
three or four right five six mats lies
that you're gonna continue to tell and
tell and tell even though everyone knows
their [ __ ] lies
but George Santos he likes all of them
he likes all the lies he wants to tell
all of them
he does not want to stop at just at
three or four he's like I want that one
I want that one I want that one yeah I
like that one too let's keep telling
them even if they contradict each other
he don't give a [ __ ] he's a republican
what the [ __ ] would he care
about people knowing that he's actually
lying
he'll give a [ __ ]
I mean otherwise he'd run as another on
another party ticket
for crying out loud
yeah George Santos so we're gonna watch
that video in the [ __ ] list Roundup I
also have a video of someone defending
him and possibly outside the capital so
we
we have uh we have a video like that I
also we have to get to when Gabe Sanchez
gets here I gotta get his opinion on the
Cheeto dust q a Niner uh giving his
deranged [ __ ] rant his shitty diaper
rant from Mar-A-Lago because it looks a
little different right
it looks different normally he's
standing in his office underneath the
[ __ ] picture of him and Kim Jong-un
shaking hands because ah he loves
authoritarians wonder why
and usually they're taking it with like
a [ __ ] cell phone right and he's
standing there in his stupid [ __ ]
golf outfit or some [ __ ] most time he
doesn't have a tie on he's got a suit on
you know that that [ __ ] suit they
tailor for him to make him seem like
he's not as fat as he is
you know this this is this is more of
this stuff where Republicans you know
are [ __ ] bigots they don't want to
they don't wanna
they don't want people to dress up and
perform right they don't want people
wearing wigs or dresses if they're not
supposed to which I don't know what the
[ __ ] that means they don't want people
wearing makeup or heels
get get putting on [ __ ] uh uh
garments that make them look different
than they truly are then their body type
truly is you know what I'm talking about
drag queens they [ __ ] hate that [ __ ]
oh God it really gets in their crawl I
don't know why just mind your own
[ __ ] business none of that shit's
your business but it really is
astounding astounding
that the person they hold up on high
they're [ __ ] Jesus
is a guy who Alters his entire
appearance and in this video it seems
like he's altering it even more
specifically for this video
you're saying well we'll get to it I'll
show it to you
guy
to give you a hint I don't know how many
tanning beds this [ __ ] owns I
don't know if he sits in a tanning bed
or if it's
nervous that goddamn tan lotion or some
[ __ ] or if it's full on make I don't
know what the [ __ ] it is but God damn
you're pissed off that people are
altering how they look
for entertainment and you people are
entertained by this fat [ __ ] slop
give me a break
he's the Maga drag queen as far as I'm
concerned and [ __ ] idiot
not to disparage drag queens that maybe
I should take that back
Tony Michaels apologizes to drag queens
all around the world comparing
um their performance and their
entertainment in any way shape or form
he formally apologizes uh maybe I'll
start trending on Twitter I don't know
[ __ ]
we'll see we'll see but that he really
he really leans into the laptop from
Hell thing right now it's gonna be the
Corvette from Hell watch oh God damn
they're gonna talk about this Corvette
like a [ __ ] I'm telling you I'm
telling you they're going to continue to
talk about this Corvette like it's some
kind of [ __ ] the most expensive
Corvette ever and he's some kind of big
Elite because he owns this Corvette or
some [ __ ]
foreign
I don't know if you remember this but
again I brought up in the first 30
minutes
um
Joe Biden won the election with that
Corbett and his aviators I don't know if
you know that I don't know if you know
that
but when he did those ads with the
Corvette
driving in the Corvette it really spoke
to the the Macho machismo males out
there believe it or not
I knew exactly what he was doing when he
was doing it Joe Biden is not a [ __ ]
idiot
the guy has not been in politics his
entire [ __ ] adult wife because he
doesn't know how to politic the guy
knows how to do it
and he did it brilliantly in 2020 with
the Corvette
this Corvette's thing is not going to be
a [ __ ] liability it's going to be an
asset that sets the narrative
telling you that's where you want to why
do you think again
do you think Donald Trump could even
[ __ ] figure out how to get his fat
ass in a Corvette
huh can you imagine trying to watch that
fat feeble [ __ ] trying to get inside of
a Corvette have you ever watched him
drive a [ __ ] golf cart
have you
he wouldn't know what to [ __ ] do in a
goddamn Corvette not a [ __ ] clue
would he have
[ __ ] bonehead especially one as nice
as Joe Biden's his prized possession the
Corvette that he owns in his garage
and of course he locked up his garage
secured his garage his [ __ ]
Corvette's sitting in there who wouldn't
lock up their Corvette expression if you
had a Corvette like that
you see how I'm doing this you see
you see what I'm doing
I don't know if you're caught on to it
this is exactly how it works exactly how
messaging works exactly how you steal
away their narrative is exactly how you
[ __ ] with them
at every single turn ever do not let up
we can't
because this [ __ ] idiot Donald Trump
is definitely definitely trying to
become president again don't [ __ ]
underestimate this
that [ __ ] is going to be their
nominee
I'm saying it it's January 12th
2023
by not this time next year they'll be
full-on primaries in the Republican
Party he's gonna be on those tickets and
he's gonna be winning some of them
yep
they're going to go to the Republican
National Committee our convention
and he's gonna have just barely probably
just barely enough delegates to win on
the floor
with first ballot
those dumb [ __ ] are gonna
nominate this stupid son of a [ __ ]
we cannot let up we cannot act like he's
not a danger anymore and we're gonna do
it the same way we did it in 2020 right
Gabe Sanchez am I correct yes correct
that is correct
and you know what I'm talking about yeah
no I don't know
all right I just I literally jumped in
and it was like and we're gonna do the
same as we did in 2020. so yeah I'm just
trying to think of what happened in 2020
you know you made a lot of content I
just I just gave the rights you just
gave the rights away to all your content
line no I'm just kidding that sounds
pretty accurate [ __ ] yeah God damn it
this would totally be something I would
make a lot of content in 2020 though I
did shitload I did I haven't made as
much this
past year no no you've been Hey listen
how many episodes of what was that are
you on right now because you're working
on one right now right or did one get
released this morning no it didn't get
released okay okay so but there's one
there's one in the hopper here yeah yeah
one I'm working on George Santos now
that I feel like there's enough stuff so
great George Santos would be episode 25.
see there you go 25 episodes that's
pretty good yeah and we're trying to do
more we're at how many are we at today
is it 308 308 that's right 308
[ __ ] that's a lot well you
remember your first episode
yeah the first one I did was it 50 yeah
the first one I did was 50 is where we
were we had Jordy and uh bread on so see
we got a shitload you got a shitload
shitload of stuff you know the reason
why I bring this up is because the
Cheeto does queuing on her he did a
video right oh yes little shitty diaper
rant and I wanna I want you to help us
break it down because there seemed to me
like of course the deranged [ __ ] that he
says is really not any different I mean
it's getting a little more deranged like
he's ticking it he's pretty it look he
looks like uh
Donald Trump in this video looks like
the woman I mean it makes sense because
he's in Florida uh it looks like that
Florida woman who has spent so much time
in the sun Outdoors that she looks like
she's a a piece of leather right and
this is like a barbecued lay chip yeah
yeah just like something that's been out
in the sun too long has been weathered
and it is something where but it's
different though isn't it though it's
yes because some of these rants we've
seen he's standing you know we've we've
done this uh time and time again where
we saw the uh the the pictures of the
classified documents on the floor with
the car right and then we looked at a
few videos and pictures of him standing
in front of the the photo of Kim Jong-un
like he loves that because he loves
authoritarian he wants to be he's like
this and crossed over right right he
loves that picture but this is different
than that because normally he'd do these
deranged rants someone's standing there
with a cell phone you can tell they're
standing with the cell phone and they're
taking uh um because it's not miked you
know he's it's obviously they're
standing away yeah yeah this has got
lights it's in a different setting so
he's chain this is produced yeah because
this is not the first one he's done
another video like this like in the last
like month or so
right so some of these are this is this
is yeah this is definitely not uh film
from the cell phone in the room in his
office in Mar-A-Lago where the documents
were discovered not you know because
typically when he does those videos he's
always like I need more money only you
can be the one that gives it to me the
your money please please give me money
I'm broke he's like look I need to clean
this money with your money you know it's
this whole thing please buy nfts
whatever those are
whatever those are trading cards I have
a a shortened version of this video but
if you
if you can't find me in the the long
version it's like uh three minutes long
in it is it on uh is it on Truth social
that might be the easiest way
oh my God
I also noticed that he puts uh he makes
his videos they're under so like he
shares them but like whenever I try to
go in and uh I'm like I'm gonna go to
rumble to go download this right oh to
lift it to lift it it's like oh this is
this is a count that doesn't allow like
basically he he shares it on true social
but it's under a private setting so you
can't access it she gotta like screen
grab this yeah [ __ ] and [ __ ] um here's
the um let's do this let's go to the
[ __ ] why were you finding that link uh
let's go to the shitless Roundup start
the countdown that's where we
we ran up all the Tweet tweets train
Trends we're gonna start with cheetah
does q and honor start the countdown
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
you got them too yeah uh hey ludens hey
ludens if you're out there we'd be
willing to do a deal yeah you know look
here just listen ready
[Music]
hold on I'll get the other one
that's a good sound that's a good sound
while you're here though subscribe to
the Tony Michaels podcast even though
we're not uh sponsored by ludens we're
just buried at them and still got the
tickle in the throat so this helps from
the little coffee cups of course a few
of them sneak through on the microphone
but you know yeah what the hell yeah how
are you gonna do it is what it is right
it is what it is you know and at least
[ __ ] like this doesn't leak through
oh my God this gay okay this is what I
said dude dude brought in
producers for this shitty diaper ramp
Mike Mike's got a shortened version of
this we're gonna go watch the whole
thing because I want to watch the whole
thing and of course he has a the one
um I'm telling you dude I don't know if
he's trying to do like
dark tan questionably blackface but it
doesn't like you think that for some guy
yeah right if it's what but here's
because he's not this dark-skinned okay
do you think it's Tanner no I mean like
I think it's just like shitty lighting
because here's the thing even on his
darkest of days I'm sorry even on his
tannest of days he's never this dark
like this looks like he has been
overcooked right he looks like Kramer in
Seinfeld whatever I've been spending so
much time under the orange the orange
light right because he fought in that
episode Kramer falls asleep in the
tanning bed exactly so it looks like he
fell asleep in the Danny bed or
something I think I think that's what
happened and they're like dude we got to
get this video out and he's like okay
okay I mean I don't think he really get
I think he thinks it looks he thinks it
looks good probably I mean I don't know
maybe the darkness he feels like can
hide the wrinkles or something like that
but he looks even worse like it looks
like he's like like a piece of jerky
that you don't want to eat right like
the guy you know I don't know the guy
not even with ketchup the guy is toast
he's over done he's overcooked like look
in more ways than one but you look at
him and he looks [ __ ] disgusting well
I will say I think he's a little jelly
too giving me a metaphor for food he's a
little jelly with his documents case oh
yeah oh man he's like I stole all of the
documents he's like whoa dude chill bro
and then they're like oh look Joe Biden
still documents and we need to
investigate put him in prison like yeah
I still I saw the best the best the best
documents
the most perfect many people are saying
many people are saying that's all the
best documents best steps ever the best
ice
classified document okay here's the
here's the little shitty diaper rant I'm
in full let's let's listen I I'm sure
I'm gonna have to pause this a couple
times but let's listen
the now famous Twitter files have proven
beyond all doubt that the corrupt
officials at the FBI have been
coordinating a massive censorship
surveillance and propaganda campaign
against the American people and frankly
against me okay so he just he just
starts out you just leave right
like not like hey hey audience hi
everyone
maybe it's your famous president maybe
the George Washington Abraham Lincoln
maybe hopefully uh he'll be lovely it's
just the guy is the guy is always
pathetic where he's like the now famous
Twitter files are they now famous or is
it a bunch of hack reporters trying well
they're influencing in a [ __ ] pile from
Twitter and you've got Elon Musk saying
oh we're gonna expose the truth and it's
like the only truth that is exposed out
of these Twitter files is that you're
[ __ ] broke or you're becoming broke
this company's gonna go [ __ ] down and
you don't know how to run a company
outside of the fact that you're not a
[ __ ] genius
well I mean
it's not
you know rocket science that oh yes the
genius why not a genius like Trump would
think that Elon and these reporters did
such a genius job I mean buffoonery
loves buffoonery I don't know I think
they're on like Edition 49 now the wait
wait they're still doing them yeah
because here's the thing remember like I
said on the show I was like all of these
line up with critical events that are
bad news against uh Donald Trump and
they had one last week
that was lined up with um
oh [ __ ] what happened last week
what didn't happen last week I remember
I remember if the the latest one I don't
know if there might have been another
one recently but the latest one last
week fell on the same day they were
doing the rules house package vote right
and so the same it basically fell under
this whole idea of like oh Republicans
can't get their [ __ ] together they can't
actually unite together when they have
the majority even though it's you know
within five people of uh because that's
what it really came down to five boats
uh but on that day that they were wrote
on the voting on The Rules package they
also dropped the Twitter files to be
like don't worry about this other
fighting that's still happening
uh focus on these Twitter files and
that's what they do the Trump org when
they got in they got charged with 17
counts of tax fraud criminal tax fraud
uh when uh any when when other news has
come out about Trump or the Trump or or
the Mar-A-Lago documents or January 6th
the they somehow
somehow are lined up with these events
that look bad for Republicans they go
haha but check this out and you're like
check this out there's some stuff on
Twitter that adds no relevance
whatsoever and it's not actual crime
it's actual procedure that the federal
government and law enforcement agencies
act in coordination with social media
sites all the time to figure out if
people are I don't know organizing crime
on it and if I if I were to guess no I
don't know but if I were to guess we
probably won't hear any Twitter files
because of the recent development with
the documents that were hanging over
that were found at Biden so much you
mean you mean next to his sweet ass
Corvette that is a [ __ ] badass car by
the way yeah I I I I again I I know I'm
bad he's a big supporter of the yeah the
American Car Mark yeah he's uh he he
loves American cars he loves American
cars he loves American classic cars as
most as most Macho real Macho real alpha
males do Gabe Sanchez I don't know if
Nick Adams knows anything about
Corvettes probably not that [ __ ]
idiot um but here's what I'll tell you I
I would almost bet that this guy with
all this Tanner on because you're right
he's got a lot of Tanner on yeah God
damn this is the video straight up this
is they're like this is this they're
like this is the best quality version
like somebody was lighting and they're
like oh uh yeah yeah we don't want to go
brighter on this one
well here's the thing do you think this
guy
could even knows how to get in a
Corvette
I mean just get in it like he would if
you said Corvette he'd probably say Kofi
like he doesn't know what uh I I highly
doubt have you you've seen him in a semi
truck right but he was like was that the
fire truck or the semi truck or did he
do it on board no it was a it was a sec
there's been a couple but the one that
was in the that actually came on to the
White House lawn was a semi it was a
semi truck and it was for it was it I
believe it was for just like the
trucking industry and he was like and I
was like oh boy it was one of the uh
infrastructure weeks at the end yeah one
of the infrastructure weeks that kind of
died out by the weekend that they didn't
actually uh pass a bill and get funding
for the American people let's continue
with this [ __ ] box let's see what else
he says we gotta we got a ways to go
here in the most recent and notorious
example the FBI worked to stop the truth
from being told about the Biden family's
criminality they work so hard to stop it
from coming out and the corruption prior
to the 2020 election they didn't want
any bad information to come out about
the Biden family the fix was in the
election was rigged but the censorship
of the laptop from hell is only the
beginning of the story about the
weaponization of government against Free
Speech okay so it really does feel like
you know remember in uh 2020 during the
summer when a bunch of these [ __ ]
Cuban honors these crazy ass
moglodytes went to the school board
meetings and they were yelling and
screaming about like CRT and vaccines
and all kinds of crazy masks and and
like they literally most time would have
their cell phones out and it felt like
they were just reading their Facebook
feed right
just reading in the Q Anon group it
almost feels like he's there like he's
right there now he's like he's just
reading what is in his [ __ ] fraud
social feed his Q Anon feed and he just
keeps reading it and repeating the
laptop from hell yeah you know he's he
lives he lives in an echo chamber like
Perpetual Echo chamber that he is locked
in he willingly locked himself in
because he was like oh everybody's
talking about me everybody has such nice
things to say look at these look at
these truths and these retrieves untruth
social right the guy just likes to live
in a place
he likes his sandbox right and he
doesn't like to leave that sandbox ever
it's a reality TV dumpster fire yeah
it's really what he's created right yeah
like he's created his own little reality
TV world where he he's everyone thinks
he's president but he's not president he
gets to declassify things with his mind
Joe bid Joe Biden doesn't uh he can hide
him in his desk drawer but Joe Biden
certainly can't have a few documents in
his garage next to his Corvette and
again I say to the audience listen if if
the documents case has is January 6 case
in mar-a-lago's case the guy stole our
documents to cover up a coup attempt Joe
Biden the documents they're fighting for
Joe Biden he was not trying to overthrow
the government
and then used his garage as a place to
hide the evidence yeah okay
he never attempted to overthrow the
government this guy did let's continue
here and again it's all projection I
mean but let's listen to more projection
I'm sure he'll do it
we must have free speech in our country
we must have a fair and Free Press as
recent reporting shows the FBI and other
Rogue agencies have been systematically
colluding with former National Security
officials placed in high positions at
Twitter and very likely other companies
what in the [ __ ] why why do these people
not understand why law enforcement it
makes sure that they communicate with
these social media sites why the [ __ ]
don't they understand this but also
let's remember who the head of the FBI
is was right at the time that Trump was
in office Christopher Ray okay
uh you know who appointed him yeah it's
it's almost like there was a guy who
asked another guy for loyalty but that
guy said no and there's another fire
right yeah he got fired yeah yeah his
name starts with the c right uh it'll
it'll come to me uh uh Comey there we go
um you know and then you've got
Christopher Ray who comes in appointed
by Trump right all the Republicans are
very upset with Christopher Ray when
Christopher Ray actually does his job
and says hey actually there was no crime
here there was none of this oh oh you
know they want a [ __ ] about all these
different things they have committees
for on committees on committees to
investigate the people investigating the
people investigating them and then when
they find out that things like Benghazi
doesn't go the way that they want they
get really pissed off they waste a bunch
of taxpayer money and here's Trump
complaining about these Twitter files
and saying oh the government the
government was working with these
companies and probably many more Trump's
government you mean
Trump's Administration Trump's J Trump's
FBI Trump's DHS Trump CIA Trump's NSA
like all these intelligent companies
intelligence companies that Trump also
[ __ ] on when they came forward to say
hey there was collusion from Russia
there believe us
in terms of I don't believe you guys you
guys are [ __ ] lying and then wants to
come out and attack them but then
believe them but then attack them but
then believe them and then now he's
saying all these agencies were working
with private companies like Twitter dude
it's literally all the time stamps look
at when they happen they happen during
your time as president before you left
office there wasn't some Mass conspiracy
of the deep State intelligence Community
that's coming after you I mean they
probably don't like you but also
it at the end of the day it's it's his
administration it's his government he
was the one who was president it's
almost as if he's like I'll take credit
for being president but I wasn't
president
to take the blame for any of this stuff
that's coming out in these now famous
Twitter files well um I I let's play the
rest of this I want to get through this
because um you sent me a link looks like
uh attorney general Merrick Garland is
going to speak at uh 1 15 Eastern which
is in about 15 minutes or so and I would
imagine he'll probably go on yeah it'd
probably be late
like 20 minutes after he'll probably
it'll probably be um
very short would be like look we're
looking into it here's the stuff we do
everything here's the facts here's the
fact here's the fact here's the fact
here's a fact you don't like facts get
the fact out and then you can always say
and then he will most likely hit them to
be like we are looking into this we are
investigating it like we should like we
always do it's not partisan it's
literally if there was something in
question then we'll look into it and the
best part is is they've uh assigned a
trump and here's another Trump appointed
that term U.S attorney so let's listen
to the Q a honor here and the only
reason why I play this video we don't
play a lot of [ __ ] from him it's because
I think this is a significant uh point
in his Rants and I think this is going
to be an inflection point of his
indictment soon but let's let's watch
to advance their censorship regime which
is really in this case to steal an
election this anti-American effort and a
very illegal effort at that has been
working to silence dissenting opinions
on covet and crucial issues on public
health and on the election and elections
in the future they suppress doctors and
health experts who dared to question
approved Public Health narratives they
censored voices who criticized school
closures lockdowns and mandates and they
even ban people simply for stating
proven scientific facts and anything bad
about China they didn't want out but
anything bad about Biden and the Biden
crime family and that's what it was just
look at the laptop from hell they didn't
want that coming out under any
circumstances what they wanted coming
out was anything bad about your favorite
President me
[Laughter]
he starts to ratchet up a couple times
in there where he's like divided crime
family right your favorite President me
and they keep they keep swapping the
views and here's why I bet because it
took him a lot of takes to do this and
he did a lot of this [ __ ] and so they
had to cut it in probably right well
here's the other thing okay so look and
this only bugs me because from just a
color grading aspect so if you look at
the shirt it looks you know the it looks
like a normal white shirt it's probably
this this shirt feels a little toned
down from a shirt that he normally wears
right uh like it might maybe maybe the
quality of the video has been you know
the brightness has been brought down her
exposure's been brought down now if you
go if you scrub back a little bit wait
for the other frame now keep in mind the
color of the shirt right now okay
it's like a white maybe there's a little
bit of a yellow tint to it the other
angle ready yeah yeah
boom okay now if you look at this this
is night and day this looks like
uh it's been given a yellow tint to it
like there's been a filter that is
already added to it it's just a color
grading thing but it bugs the [ __ ] out
of me because on one it's like yeah it's
mostly true to the color of the shirt I
guess because you also
when you're filming you can use white as
your color balance right right like a
like marker Point kind of thing
yeah yeah you'd be like all right here's
a bunch of colors I can use the white as
the base and I can establish oh it's too
blue it's too yellow right on the scale
now in this one you're like yeah it
looks looks about right okay looks okay
but then if you go back to the other one
then you'll realize that you go from
white to a
oh you want me to go back yeah just
where it was yeah okay see right they
flip really quick yeah really quick you
can see it so it's here it's yellow and
then you go back and then it's white but
like if you go back and forth you can
see that it's it's a it's a [ __ ]
different color so somebody added a
yellow filter to this angle for whatever
reason it's also there's a lot going on
with it well here's the thing is I told
the audience earlier that um I wanted to
have you on to to analyze this because I
know it it they're trying to uh over
produce this video really yeah honestly
it's just it's just a [ __ ] rant that
he's doing that they're overproducing
they're making it feel like an official
stupid president's speech with the
[ __ ] blanks behind him and [ __ ] and
and the carry Lake type filter where
it's like blurred you know yeah yeah
I mean this one is like man it's okay
right and for anyone who doesn't know
there's this is called a bokeh effect
where you've got you know the their your
foreground uh uh subject in focus and
the background right blurry on your
iPhone it's called portrait right
exactly yeah you have a portrait mode on
there that you can use that's basically
What's Happening Now Kerry Lake
obviously has it too like oh my God the
nth degree right uh where it looks like
her background's melting yeah it looks
like she's she's stuck behind or like
stuck in front of I guess wax paper
right uh but in this video right here
you've got this guy who is like and it
has to go we're only halfway into this
video here and this guy is getting more
and more agitated as he talks about
buying well but but it could be yeah but
it could be Gabe at that these different
cuts he got more and more agitated as
yeah as possible as he had to do more
and more Cuts because he would probably
do a few lines he'd [ __ ] it up and then
they'd stop and he'd do a few more lines
just like he did with the after the
January 6 we watched um those outtakes
uh of some of those [ __ ] crazy ass
rants from there let's let's continue
here anything bad about Trump put it out
even if it's not true but this all had
nothing to do with science this had
nothing to do with saving lives it had
everything to do with politics or a sick
ideology this was about government
working with powerful corporations to
seize power over you the American people
and we can't let that continue the
Twitter files proved that we urgently
need my plan to dismantle the illegal
censorship regime a regime like nobody's
ever seen in the history of our country
or most other country does he say the
word Matrix God damn it I want to know
so go back can you go back because he
doesn't say Twitter files he says tutor
files Desi scooter files
government working with powerful
corporations to seize power over you the
American people and we can't let that
continue the Twitter files prove that we
urgent the tutor files
it's not a tumor
oh my God keep going you [ __ ] fool
keep going dig your hole let's listen I
really need my plan to dismantle the
illegal censorship regime a regime like
nobody's ever seen in the history of our
country or most other countries for that
matter
to prosecute the perpetrators for their
crimes and to restore free speech for
all Americans okay okay this is the
whole remember the um there was a guy
who ran in 2016. and he won on
technicality yeah yeah and and there was
a there was a thing that his audiences
would chant over and over and over and
it's almost like he didn't do that thing
who would did he want to prosecute what
was the who was the her it was lock her
up oh lock her
I think it was I think it's the owner of
CNN the Clinton News Network that's
right that's right Hillary Clinton is
the one he wanted to lock up he had four
years and he still couldn't do it so you
we're really gonna trust that this guy
can lock up whoever is responsible
for four years to do a lot of things he
had four years to finish a wall he
didn't do it yeah to lock up Hillary
Clinton didn't do it he had four years
to make America great again which debate
made it worse yeah which you make it
worse he had 4 four years to help the
middle class he [ __ ] him over with a
tax cut in jobs act he had four years to
prove that
um he would get a health care plan
remember he was going to have the health
care plan remember he's gonna be the
greatest one ever never happened he said
two weeks two weeks two weeks he kept he
told he told uh a bunch of people every
interview he had two weeks he had uh uh
Kaylee mcinanny give
um uh her soul to the devil no well she
handed it she handed that there's that
photo it was on 16. oh yeah yeah right
and handed a big binder of of women oh
it's the hell yeah it was the health
care plan but it was just blank they're
like here's this big book and then it
was like there's nothing in here it's
just a [ __ ] I wonder if the dwara
files is in that folder okay
okay and so important we need a free
press we need free speech we need Fair
elections and we need borders the new
Congress should immediately hold
hearings to investigate the role of the
FBI and other federal agencies in
censoring lawful speech Congressional
leaders should promptly issue subpoenas
in furtherance of this goal the
revelations also highlight why my
proposal to end the revolving door
between the Deep State and there is a
deep State indeed I wasn't a Believer
but everybody's a Believer right now and
the tech he wasn't a Believer is that
what he said Trump is part of the deep
State guys if there was ever a deep
State Trump is definitely a part of it
he's also the first he's in deep [ __ ]
State that's for sure he is also the
person that was uh filling the swamp
that he also claimed in four years he
would drain all right that's another
thing that he was supposed to do through
nepotism and competence uh greed
uh just don't give a [ __ ] attitude about
Americans you know I he overflowed the
swamp and now everyone wants to still
wants to drain it I'm noticing something
else about this video they spent a lot
of time on the lighting here and the
setting they really didn't get the
microphone right and I don't know if he
was like yelling into it they're like
Jesus moved that microphone back and he
kept yelling like well I'm sure I'm sure
because like I was saying earlier like
he's he was like ratcheting up and down
his terms of like when he's talking
about the Biden crime family and your
favorite present me me uh were his like
his like ebb and flow where I'm sure the
person who maybe was following the audio
levels is like
because you know I'm sure someone if he
was doing that then that person's also
like [ __ ] man like I can I can Max you
out on the p week but you might have to
follow the person and be like when you
go really high I have to go low to yeah
but you're giving a lot of credit you're
saying they have an audio technician
which I mean I'm assuming it's also
probably you know some some kid they
pulled from from the Mar-A-Lago links
you know right right something something
let's finish here
tyrants is so important there must be a
seven year cooling off period before any
employee of these powerful agencies is
allowed to take a job at a major
platform when I'm President we will take
back our freedoms we will take back our
country
and they're like all right just cut it
just cut it
what is it saying you're cooling off
period what the [ __ ] is he talking about
I I don't know this is like typically
when you work for a company especially
if it's a tech company you might have a
non-compete Clause but even in the state
of California California is very
pro-employee so the idea that someone
can hold you to say you can't work at
this other company is still debatable
even if you sign it in your contract to
be like you worked for this uh
technology company and we have certain
IP that we don't want other people to
know about so we need to say for 12
months you cannot go into a competitive
uh or a competitors company for the sake
of allowing them to have an advantage in
the market but I don't know what the
[ __ ] the seven year cooling period is
it's like
I the last time I heard seven years I
don't know I'm I'm not even sure what
he's talking about and I'm not sure why
seven years seems very uh
odd arbitrary it's arbitrary like it's
not like a common law marriage
it's probably because he's got a couple
people in mind that you know are at six
years or six and a half years and they
get that seven year that way he's like
probably also hoping he's like look if
we wait seven years and it's past the
point at which I can be you know
convicted of Allah it's like what do you
think right exactly there's something
going on here he didn't pull seven years
out of his head he probably didn't he
might have been seven years he's like
seven Lucky Seven yeah that works that's
a lot of people are saying like somebody
said seven in the room and it goes seven
years yeah that sounds good that's good
seven years I'm your favorite friend
it's me
um I I want to make sure that we're
keeping track of the house floor here I
told the audience that we would uh keep
monitors on the America First Nazi party
that has uh controlled Our House of
Representatives by the slimmest of
margins with the uh speaker being Kevin
MacArthur did a facto speak group being
Marjorie Taylor green but this here
this video here someone put this
together
um to give a roll call here I just want
to make sure everyone sees this roll
call this is [ __ ] hilarious by the
way this is from Bad rip lip reader
Jesus bad
they've had quite the week they have
this one's man this one's a good one
have you seen this one yeah yeah oh this
one the ending on this one oh my God I
couldn't stop [ __ ] laughing yesterday
let's listen
vein guy
you should see my car
stink suit
check out my frown it's jumbled code
marvelous
the bees unwashed knees now it's just
bee's knees can you mention that we
changed it
you just did
Chevy dude
penguins
good point
sad euphoria
I'm not lonely
sounds convincing
look tool
oh
don't care for the tools the pink
ghosting
I got plenty guacamole in the business
office
oh my God the ending I got plenty of
guacamole in the business office
oh bad lip readers please do not stop
yeah please do not stop I just I just
wish that you know we had the ability to
have these different camera angles so I
so I when I was working what was that
and I was wrapping up last night I was
looking for an article to be like oh I
just want to you know clarify some of
the like how the
how the cameras work and I had to cut a
line
from the from the segment I did because
in there I was like well typically and
this is how it normally works for people
who don't know and yes we are going to
go to the mayor Garland announcement uh
in just a moment
um we're just waiting on that kind of to
start so yeah I I'm monitoring it so
once it starts and he comes with Podium
we'll put bring in upholstery so uh for
people who don't know the way the
cameras work are during the week in
which you've written in limbo right
nobody's in control of the house then
um C-SPAN runs the cameras right and
that's why we were able to see a lot of
what was happening and what do you mean
by run the cameras is like the angles
yeah so they determine which cameras
running everything Which Way But when
it's obviously run by the party that's
in power and this happens for both
parties Democrats and Republicans they
control to only have certain cameras
looking over to the speaker looking over
to the clerk looking over the person
that's talking and then there's a
general house view right and there was a
camera angle that happened obviously
during the segment of uh of Mike Rogers
lunging at Matt Gates which I don't know
if people saw this but Matt Gates was
like making them like making a muscle
and pointing to his arm afterwards like
he was like yeah are you serious yeah
that's hilarious but basically
um Matt Gates now has proposed that
C-SPAN either get control of the cameras
because C-SPAN also was like hey we want
to put other cameras in that we can
control right you guys can have your own
cameras but we want to have our
independent camera so we can run it
because there was a lot of interest a
lot of people like holy [ __ ] this drama
happening right now this is great
well because you could actually see the
floor you could actually see it right
and so Matt Gates has proposed the idea
that we should give them access this guy
this guy
let me tell you something this guy
um is is scummy as he is
has had some great ideas he was gonna
resign
um if there was a moderate that's a
great idea
um let's see what else what else was
gonna happen uh that Matt Gates had a
great he was getting he was going to
resign
um this camera idea I'm not against this
idea yeah I mean he said some things
where I'm like oh wow
we're gonna go to um we're gonna go to
the um
um announcement yeah announcement here
real quick hang on hang on uh he is at
the stage now congratulations I have to
pull locations I'm gonna pull it back to
President Biden the question today for
the
classified documents were handled
attorney general Mr Garland
good afternoon
I'm here today to announce the
appointment of Robert Herr as a special
counsel pursuant to Department of
Justice regulations governing such
matters
in keeping with those regulations I have
today notified the designated members of
each house of Congress of the
appointment
I'm joined today by John lausch the U.S
attorney for the northern district of
Illinois who conducted the initial
investigation into the matter that I
will describe today
on the evening of November 4th 2022 the
National Archives office of Inspector
General
contacted a prosecutor at the Department
of Justice
it informed him that the White House had
notified the archives that documents
bearing classification markings were
identified at the office of the Penn
Biden Center for diplomacy and Global
engagement
located in Washington DC
that office was not authorized for
storage of classified documents
the prosecutor was also advised that
those documents had been secured in an
archives facility
on November 9th the FBI commenced an
assessment consistent with standard
protocols to understand whether
classified information had been
mishandled in violation of federal law
on November 14th pursuant to section
600.2 B of the special counsel
regulations I assigned U.S attorney
lausch to conduct an initial
investigation to inform my decision
whether to appoint a special counsel
Mr laosch has served as a U.S attorney
in Chicago since 2017. before that he
spent more than a decade as an assistant
U.S attorney in that same office
I selected him to conduct the initial
investigation because I was confident
his experience would ensure that it
would be done professionally and
expeditiously
on December 20th President Biden's
personal counsel informed Mr lauch that
additional documents bearing
classification markings were identified
in the garage of the president's private
residents in Wilmington Delaware
President Biden's Council informed Mr
laust that those documents were among
other records from the period of the
president's Service as vice president
the FBI went to the location and secured
those documents
on January 5th 2023 Mr lausch briefed me
on the results of his initial
investigation and advised me that
further investigation by a special
counsel was warranted
based on Mr lausch's initial
investigation I concluded that under the
special counsel regulations it was in
the public interest to appoint a special
counsel
in the days since while Mr laosch
continued the investigation the
department identified Mr Herr for
appointment a special counsel
this morning President Biden's personal
counsel called Mr laosch and stated that
an additional document bearing
classification markings was identified
at the president's personal residence in
Wilmington Delaware
when I first contacted Mr lausch about
this matter he said he could lead the
initial investigation but would be
unable to accept any longer-term
assignment because he would be leaving
the department in early 2023 for the
private sector
U.S attorney lausch and his team of
prosecutors and agents have conducted
this initial investigation with
professionalism and speed
I am grateful to them
earlier today I saw I signed an order
appointing Robert Herr a special counsel
for the matter I've just described
the document authorizes him to
investigate whether any person or entity
violated the law in connection with this
matter
the special counsel will not be subject
to the day-to-day supervision of any
official of the department but he must
comply with the regulations procedures
and policies of the department
Mr Herr has a long and distinguished
career as a prosecutor in 2003 he joined
the Department's Criminal Division where
he worked on counter-terrorism corporate
fraud and appellate matters
from 2007 until 2014 Mr Herr served as
an assistant U.S attorney for the
District of Maryland where he prosecuted
matters ranging from violent crime to
financial fraud
in 2017 Mr hurry joined the Department
as the principal associate Deputy
Attorney General
in 2018 he was nominated and confirmed
to serve as a U.S attorney for the
District of Maryland as U.S attorney he
supervised some of the Department's more
important National Security public
corruption and other high-profile
matters
I will ensure that Mr Herr receives all
the resources he needs to conduct his
work
as I have said before
I strongly believe that the normal
processes of this department can handle
all investigations with integrity
but under the regulations the
extraordinary circumstances here require
the appointment of a special counsel for
this matter
this appointment underscores for the
public the Department's commitment to
both Independence and accountability in
particularly sensitive matters and to
making decisions indisputably guided
only by the facts and the law
I am confident that Mr Herr will carry
out his responsibility in an even-handed
and Urgent Manner and in accordance with
the highest traditions of this
department
thank you all have you ever spoken to
the president okay there is that mayor
Garland he's just gonna walk off he's
definitely not going to take any
questions at this point I don't believe
um because that that's the whole point
of it is just come out and give the
statement I want to tell you I'm excited
about this Gabe Sanchez this this a lot
of people are going to freak out about
this but this actually puts Maga in a a
really tough position um Margie points
it out um perfectly that it puts him in
a really tough pickle because here
Merrick Garland
has done the fair thing of saying you
know what if the classified documents
shits the same we'll appoint a special
counsel it'll be separate because
they're two separate issues guess what
[ __ ] you're you can't def what
what is what are the House Republicans
gonna try to do are they gonna try to
defend one special counsel and not the
other yeah they can't I mean the thing
is they're going
it is it is hilarious because it's it's
this moment of wait well I but you did
you can't do right no like that's what's
gonna end up happening because what
we're seeing here is that mayor Garland
goes yeah okay fine you want a special
counsel I'll [ __ ] give you a special
counsel and just so you know we were
investigating we did an initial review
we saw this you know of course magazine
where's the raid where's the raid they
didn't need a raid because they called
the FBI to come get the [ __ ] listen I'm
telling you this is good for the country
this is good for the country this is an
exercise in showing the showing people
that these two parties are not the same
it's not the same [ __ ] it's not the same
intent it is not the same and really
um
I hope that the House Republicans really
dig into this investigators of the
investigators of the investigators it's
going to be fantastic it's only going to
reveal how [ __ ] ridiculous they are
and how thin their narratives are and
how much lies they tell every single
moment of every single [ __ ] day about
their crooked ass deep State swampiness
because it's them it's them
for [ __ ] sake I want to show you the
uh Marjorie Taylor green uh tweet here
uh from this morning I told the audience
I'd give them that
um just because
uh it is bone-headed this boneheaded can
get about this documents case she
clearly does not understand the other
thing I want to bring up while we're
talking about this real quick when I'm
looking into this tweet
um
it's this
I don't know if the House Republicans
know this or not I'm not sure if they're
aware of this Joe Biden is the president
of the United States now if the
narrative that Donald Trump and his
allies push for [ __ ] years and
continue to push that the president or a
former president can't be prosecuted
because they have immunity
that applies here if you're gonna make
that argument yeah if you're gonna make
that argument it applies here and if you
really think that Donald Trump could
have pardoned himself which a lot of
these [ __ ] idiots said that [ __ ] if
you truly believe it guess what you also
have to believe at the exact same time
that Joe Biden because he's the
president of the United States
yes in fact if Donald Trump can do it so
can Joe Biden as the president United
States
um God damn it I'm not buying this tweet
that [ __ ] idiot oh here it is here it
is I've had it I got it
I got it here okay here is this is on
her official account this is so stupid
man this is this is dumb as dog [ __ ] you
think Twitter should actually have like
a marking like that dumbest dog [ __ ]
yeah
so this is on her official account
she says only POTUS can declassify docs
not the vice the vice president cannot
he is the president he's the president
he is the president
Joe Biden was vice president when he
stole classified documents there is no
evidence not a shred of it that he stole
anything again Merrick Garland just laid
out the facts that these documents based
on a United States Attorney in his
office's investigation that these
documents are documents from when he was
the president our vice president excuse
me didn't steal anything my guess is
there's proper protocol for these
documents now
um she goes on to puke up by or excuse
me but why would his own attorneys
reveal that he had them at the Biden
Center because they're not scumbags like
you
yeah
why would they because they found them
they're like oh [ __ ] these can't be here
we need to go to follow the proper
procedure now what she's saying is why
didn't they publicly say it because it
wasn't a public matter yeah they found
them they returned them the doj open the
investigation
uh especially after the FBI raids on
Trump's home oh yeah it's always about
your [ __ ] orange Mussolini Jesus
that's the other thing that I think that
these people are not gonna [ __ ]
comprehend that these two things Trump's
documents the case against January 6 and
him trying to cover up a kangaroo coup
by stealing our documents from our
government
is not not even the same as these
documents this documents again they were
taken
after 2016 before 2020. yeah but he
didn't even know he was gonna run in
2016 you stupid [ __ ] Trump has always
known he's gonna rerun here
um and then their last her last question
don't you get the sense that they're
she's doing like the Tucker especially
at the FBI raided Trump's home what are
they hiding if they're trying to
preemptively stop especially after FBI
rate on Trump's home well I'm just
asking questions why would his attorney
reveal that he had him at the Biden
Center these are questions why don't we
know this
Tyler green also might ask like why do I
have three toes right I don't know right
it's what the god the Creator the person
upstairs wants to do for himself all
right so I'm just gonna go back to
CrossFit
CrossFit oh God that's a whole nother
subject so here we um her ending
question here is what are they hiding
or trying to preemptively stop now again
there's no preempting to this yeah she's
projecting here when she's saying Trump
is trying to hide things and
preemptively stop something by stealing
documents and harboring them at
Mar-A-Lago and not giving them back
because the evidence shows that he tried
to overthrow our government and that is
why the FBI had to raid his home that is
why his attorneys not only did they not
want to give back these arguments but
they lied on forms to the FBI doj and
Nara they're like we swear we gave you
everything and he did and he did steal
these documents he did steal these
documents yeah and and yes yes the the
president United States candies
classified but not with his mind all
this in this statement is is what Trump
did yeah what she is doing here is
describing everything that Trump did
everything that Trump did so do not let
audience do not be scared of this case
do not be scared of a special counsel uh
appointment of a special counsel doesn't
mean there's crime committed it just
means if you have you heard Merrick
Garland at the the United States
Attorney that he appointed after they
found these documents to investigate to
make sure
is leaving service
as of 2023 because he's a trump
appointed United States Attorney
generally speaking they move on because
the new Administration wants to appoint
another United States Attorney
that is within their purview to and
their agenda to to actually fill those
posts
um so there he's going to move to the
private sector this investigation isn't
done because they found a few more
documents in a few more places so Merit
Garland is appointing a special counsel
to pick up
where this attorney that Trump appointed
this United States Attorney out of out
of Illinois and that's right right he
was out of Illinois yeah out of Illinois
he's going to pick up where he left off
and the special counsel is going to
finish this investigation that's all
that means that's all that means so
don't get scared actually lean into this
this is it this is a good thing I mean
look let's let's understand once again
this is exactly exactly what Republicans
asked for the last two days they've been
[ __ ] [ __ ] in a moment Josh was like
he said special counsel okay dude you
got what you wanted man look anytime
what's what is hilarious here is that
when Trump continuously lied made new
excuses pulled new new reasons out of
his ass said it was planted said he
Declassified said it was it was a hoax
said it was this said it was that like
all of these things head spinning
excuses all of the [ __ ] reasons he
gave Republicans continue to back him
again and again and again
by saying oh no yeah he's true those are
his documents he can have those those
are definitely his he can have those no
no he can do whatever he wants uh
they're Memoirs they're mementos he's
scrapbooking he's doing this that's all
bunch of [ __ ] all lies and and they
always move in the goal post right the
Biden Administration Biden himself this
morning read a statement from his legal
counsel he didn't go on some [ __ ]
crazy ass rant and tweet it out he
handed it like you would normally handle
like he handled it oh you normally
handle it right and this was another
example we're not moving the goal post
they're not changing their delivery you
want you want it to be fair because
obviously if Merrick Garland was like we
looked into it and we didn't see
anything wrong obviously Republicans be
like oh which bye this is fine you know
what here's your special counsel just
like you [ __ ] bitched and moaned
about you want it it's only fair if
there's wrongdoing they'll investigate
it sure you're going to have their team
ready to go so now Merrick Garland says
we have we have appointed Robert Herr he
has a long history he's also again all
of these people worked under the Trump
Administration
they were appointed under the Trump
Administration uh in 2017 2018 they
moved their way up and they worked under
the Trump Administration in the doj
these people are under these people come
from that side they come from Trump's
World while he was President so that's
one thing if you want to point out to
people the second is that again it's
completely Fair we got a special counsel
to investigate Trump lying and cheating
and taking these documents they also get
a special counsel to find that they were
documents taken under Biden they're
going to figure out exactly what
happened they're going to investigate
just like they wanted and I can tell you
right now Tucker Carlson tonight is
gonna [ __ ] [ __ ] and moan and talk
about this crazy yeah hypocritical what
about autism freak out and say that even
though they got what they wanted they
didn't really get what they wanted which
was to impeach Biden right taking the
documents well I mean maybe maybe they
tried to do it but I I mean again folks
I want you to be excited about this
appointment of special counsel this is a
good thing for the country this is a
horror horrible thing for Trump anything
that's good for the country is horrible
for Trump and Republicans to be quite
honest
um and here's the thing that Marjorie
Taylor green statement Gabe Sanchez that
is the same
the exact same Marjorie Taylor green
who in the in the final days of Kevin
McCarthy finally getting
finally getting
his speakership she sat next to George
Santos
over and over again joking with him
pointing at the ceiling his ceiling
pointing at the her pin on her dress all
kinds of crazy laughing giggling
they love each other right so let me ask
you Gabe Sanchez do you believe anything
that anyone who would Embrace George
Santos would say at all
no not a goddamn word of it not a
goddamn word of it but I think let me
show you a video is this a new one this
is a new one this is from this morning
we're gonna get we get our daily Chase
video because he goes he goes from his
office to the elevator and they're like
I know this is honestly this is this is
a uh uh an amazing crazy sequel to catch
me if you can right well I mean every
single time uh but today is special in
this video today's special eight Sanchez
because he says something as he gets
into the elevator let's see if you can
get it I'm a fraud I'm a crook let's see
if you catch it Congressman what's your
reaction to members of your own party
calling for your resignation
is
did you catch it there 142 people is
that I don't know I I think we got we
got we got about 1600 people right now
watching this show can we get 142 of
them and ask George Santos to resign uh
because that's what he said 142 people
well I think he's he's talking about the
Congress but he says people not members
yeah yeah because he doesn't he doesn't
you know if 142 people I'm just I'm I'm
catching this on Reuters right now U.S
rep Santos opens door to resignation
it's 142 people ask now I again I'm not
it depends on what your definition of
ask is and people
um I'm I'm just joking I actually do not
want George Santos to resign I want this
every single day to get the clip of them
chasing him every [ __ ] day every day
every single one of them he's running to
the elevator because here's the thing
those are congressional elevators so
those are Reserve remembrance conference
so that's why they can't like get on the
elevator with him once they get in the
elevator that's it Senators do the same
thing on the Senate side they get their
elevators yeah once they get in the
elevator that's it you gotta leave leave
them alive I don't know I mean I would
think that the person who is the star
volleyball player who led Baruch College
to uh the national championship I heard
that about him that he's some sort of
really he's a crazy crazy like a beach
body to be quiet I mean I don't know
when I see that and I think of
volleyball you could be an extra in
absolutely [ __ ] Top Gun yeah man just
like a beach volleyball scene but wait
wait was it beach volleyball or just
volleyball that he was he was camping
I thought you're talking about Top Gun
no no no no regular volleyball right
okay well you know I mean most
volleyball players though uh rather
they're gym volleyball players or beach
volleyball players they typically have a
an athletic type structure yeah they're
also you know typically they're taller
uh they're leaner they're more athletic
they have to be taller to play
volleyball but it's an advantage well if
you're gonna play up on the net do you
like to watch volleyball I don't watch
it too I don't I don't really want
really volleyball I mean the only time I
watch it is maybe if I like I'm skimming
through the like the Summer Olympics I
get yeah well the Summer Olympics that's
one of my favorites to watch it's not
just the beach volleyball the gym
volleyball
um when when back it's my days when I
was a young man we love to go to
volleyball games yeah our school that I
went to they were the girls were [ __ ]
fantastic at volleyball they kicked ass
um and we went and we supported them
like a [ __ ] I mean we cheer them
on we yell and scream and they won they
won a lot they were really good so we
really like to watch volleyball I I I
like it it's a it's a cool sport it's a
fun sport it's fun to play
you know but you gotta have decent knees
and [ __ ] so you guys shoot your knees oh
man it really knees and ankles you gotta
have knees and ankles for this yeah and
elbows you got to have good cartilage oh
yeah [ __ ] yeah your joints got to be in
damn good shape I mean not only do you
have to be athletic but you got to have
a lot of cartilage in there but I'll
tell you one thing let me tell you this
as fast as he is uh he's scurrying away
from um run the reporters here let me
show you I mean you don't see the feet
they're probably like working double
time right I mean this guy he definitely
could not
um excuse me he could not be a
volleyball player there's no way I mean
he could play volleyball
and I I think I said this yesterday I
was like how old is he again he's 30 20
50 34. wait 40.
he's 67. here's the timeline ready
here's the timeline for people who don't
know so he said he went to uh I haven't
because I was writing this this morning
uh he said he went to Horace Mann
college or a Horseman school high school
in the Bronx can you do this I I need a
I need a quick um yeah go ahead tell the
audience about all these new lies and
then I'll I'll be I'll be right back
okay
so just to give people context to the
new lies that are happening which I
don't even have all of them yet as I'm
like putting the information together
for the what was that but I can tell you
right now if we go if we start from the
beginning to give you an idea of how old
he is or how old he is he he says that
he went to Horace Mann school in the
Bronx private school his parents put him
in the parents both emigrated from
Brazil all right so he was supposed to
he he dropped out and then he ended up
getting a GED I think is what really was
found out but he was supposed to
graduate in 2008 right
Nanny on his resume if people want to
check out his resume the uh the New York
Times has his official resume uh
actually on file let me see if I can
pull that up uh uh yeah here we go I'll
put the link in there right now and you
guys can read
the
boom all right so I just put in the chat
this is George Santos's resume all right
so he also says that he graduated from
Baruch College in 2010 right so that
means he he completed a four-year degree
in two years and he was also the star
volleyball player of Baruch College he
he led them to the championship which
Nassau County uh GOP official yesterday
was like he told me that he was this and
I believed him it's almost as if they
didn't do any sort of vetting
so then we find out that there's a whole
new thing that's going on not only did
he lie about his mother dying which he
supposedly died twice we don't even know
if she's actually dead or not who knows
uh but there's also this idea that
there's this money that has come out of
nowhere right this mysterious
unregistered fund that has raised big
money for Santos right so a month before
George Santos elected to congress one of
his large donors received a call asking
him to consider making another sizable
contribution and what we also need to
realize that also is like the group had
already raised the group had already
raised 800 000 and was seeking another
seven hundred thousand dollars according
to this email that was sent and the
donor came through days later on October
21st he sent twenty five thousand
dollars to a Wells Fargo Bank belonging
to Redstone strategies now what people
also need to remember here is that this
guy is getting money from random places
right he said he was a landlord never
was actually a landlord he was getting
money from here he had money from a
company that he said he that he worked
for he said he worked for Goldman Sachs
he said he worked for Citigroup neither
one of those places he worked for he
worked for a link Bridge strategies I
think is what is actually called or link
Bridge uh and what he said was he
facilitated the meeting of of people
like Goldman Sachs in Citigroup so we're
finding this new money is coming out one
of which The Daily Beast broke last
night which was it was uh he took a
donation from a migrant Smuggler
serializer what what yeah they're dude
there is so much so the Miami the Miami
lawyer is one aspect of this financial
board and then there's a migrant but it
turns out that he accepted support from
an Italian caught piling a yacht full of
Chinese migrants
and his prominent wrestling only owning
family so this guy is getting money from
a bunch of [ __ ] yeah dude it's crazy
that's what I'm saying like when I was
originally writing this okay have you
ever have you ever seen the movie and
then there's a new version why I say new
but I mean there's a a new word it's
like 20 years old but there's an old
movie called The Manchurian Candidate
yep remember that yeah it really feels
yeah but the Manchurian Candidate is it
is not aware of what's going on there's
like a trigger that activates them this
guy is just like
uh he's gonna he's gonna oh I was uh I
was a man I was a uh leave leave
strobler I think it was the Venturian
yes yeah well yeah in the in the newest
in the newest one right but actually did
they didn't they do it didn't they do a
uh some kind of like Netflix series or
some [ __ ] or I don't know they might
have they might have but I mean
Manchurian Candidate is not aware
there's there they've been they've been
they've been rammed right right and then
there's this there's an activation word
or a series like yeah yeah like they say
a word and right and then
boom destroy the government
but this guy is so incompetent and so
terrible like if you're gonna lie people
who are listening guys if you're gonna
tell a lie at least have some truth to
it at least have something that you can
back up with it but what he does is is
Santos lies and then he just makes up a
new lie to cover for that lie and
it's insane so this new story like I
don't even have all the facts on this
one yet I'm still trying to catch up and
I that's that's the reason when this
stuff came out before the new year
because keep in mind this all broke
around Christmas of 2022 so not even a
month ago this stuff broke
okay
I was starting I was like oh who is
George Santos you know like joking like
where who in the world is George Santos
like Carmen San Diego and I thought of
this and I was like ah you know what I'm
gonna hold off on doing this story
because I feel like what's gonna happen
is this is just the this is just the
[ __ ] tip of the iceberg tip of the
live Iceberg there is going to be way
more that's going to come out so I'm
going to hold off I'm not gonna do it
and then I got covet and I was like I'm
definitely not gonna do it right now
because I sounded like I gotta I gotta
speaking of a video I got a video from
someone outside the capitol oh yeah this
is um
uh they they may or may not be
um advocating for George Santos to stay
in congress I actually am I'm dead
serious about I do not want him to
resign I do not no I want I want them to
have to pay for every [ __ ] one of his
lies even before he uh even before he
was elected or Not Elected but even
before he was um uh sworn in right
because we were talking about this last
week which feels like a millennia ago uh
he was he was you know and also there's
a lot of lies again also also I just
remembered this when they were talking
about gutting which they pretty much
have gutted the office of congressional
ethics right remember that yeah George
Santos said that's a fantastic idea well
of course he would think that's a great
idea that's why they're doing it for him
and uh other all of them well yeah and
that's why that's why Kevin McCarthy he
was asked yesterday in the hall they're
like yo are you going to condemn what he
did he's like what has he been charged
with he he's proven guilty and the only
reason he wants him is because he needs
that vote if anyone watched what
happened last week it shows you that his
his control literally sits within four
to five votes well and here's the thing
that Kevin McCarthy promised for that
vote for George Santos because George
Santos had to get something at bare
minimum he's probably on the Ethics
Committee right well he's he's
definitely not going to be removed
Let's uh let's listen to this video here
about George Santos
the Democrats keep calling for him to
resign just because he supposedly lied
about a few things
you know last time I checked freedom of
speech is still legal in America yeah is
it a crime to lie about your alma mater
crime to lie about working at Goldman
Sachs
it's being gay being Jewish or your
mother dying on 9 11 I mean who Among Us
hasn't lied about being a gay half white
half black Jewish City Group Goldman
Sachs employee with a degree from Baruch
College who employed mass shooting
victims descended from Holocaust
Survivors and whose mother died on two
separate days
are they going to make it a crime to use
eleven thousand dollars in campaign
funds to pay your own rent I mean
because if that was illegal then half
Republicans would be in jail right now
I don't know who that is Walter Walter
showing up on the capitol lawn again uh
yeah and for anyone who's wondering that
is uh Walter Masterson he's doing satire
is it's a whole it's hilarious he's a
comedian so yeah yeah just in case
you're confused yeah okay because here's
honestly you could look at that and
you'd be like oh that looks like it
could be what we heard last week it's
hard to distinguish the satire anymore
when you have Donald Trump putting out
videos like he had yeah that we just
watched uh tweet Marjorie Taylor green
tweeting the exact crimes that Trump has
committed and placing them on Biden
because they found a [ __ ] a couple
documents that were classed that had
classified mark workings from when he
was the vice president and they turned
him over immediately as soon as they
found them there's no fishy thing in
this investigation yet mayor Garland
even said that the United States
Attorney that was appointed by Donald
Trump in Illinois has has said no
there's nothing fishy here but it does
it need a special counsel because it's
not finished until it's finished you
really need to appoint a special counsel
because I'm going to go in the way of I
don't know you know the private sector
I'm gonna quit yeah you know now I I do
want to pull up Allison's tweet here
Mueller she wrote
um I've actually tried to get her on the
show today to talk about this which um
and great fashion and so maybe we'll try
to get her on tomorrow man she just
she's got a few things she's she's doing
uh in this uh in this second hour here
now that I keep her from being on the
show but
she says breaking thread because this is
about another special counsel Gabe
Sanchez uh Jack Smith sent out a massive
round of subpoenas on December 9th man
they include subpoenas to Trump campaign
officials with new questions about who
funded lawyers for the witnesses uh to a
potential investigation and obstruction
of justice uh number two two dozen
categories of information uh
Communications or information about
dominion and smartmatic sounds like my
pillow guys territory trying to
establish whether anyone knew the
conspiracies were false uh they did
definitely knew that [ __ ] was false
Fox News has even admitted it uh so is
Newsmax I believe I don't know if oan's
got that far but and they're trying to
say no it was all entertainment we
didn't actually believe that [ __ ] even
Sean Hannity right Sean Anthony in the
deposition said that that was all
[ __ ] we knew it was [ __ ] yeah
I'm here is uh here's another subpoena
information on uh Trump entities
besides to save America pact including
make America great again packed to save
America joint fundraising Committee in
the Trump Maga committee and any groups
affiliated with them this is so funny
because we play a parody commercial that
you do
um a lot here on the show and you did
that video what is it was it in 2020
when you did that or was that the
beginning of 2021 no no it was uh let me
see I think I was and that's the reason
why I keep playing it because literally
literally you're you're saying in there
exactly what the crime was it's not hard
to see this stuff that's hilarious I
believe it was in 2021 I mean if I were
to go back also information uh she
reports information on the election
quote the election defense fund if I was
Donald Trump Jr then I would do it like
this
um election defense fund uh she goes on
that's the one that the one six
committee found didn't actually exist so
the election defense fund is the one
that doesn't exist in the select
committee went whoa where is this money
going and uh he wants Jack Smith wants
to know where the hell the money was uh
went and she goes on to say more
information on the fraudulent elector
scheme this is where I think they're
really in hot [ __ ] trouble
um with the coup attempt now the finance
thing the finance thing they're
completely [ __ ] yeah and anything do
that and they stole that money and they
defrauded those people people for that
money you are in big trouble Financial
crimes the Department of Justice does
not [ __ ] around with in this country I
don't know if you ever heard of Bernie
Madoff what's that new guy what's that
new game the the FTX game what the
[ __ ] his name oh we're uh Sam yeah Sam
yeah yeah yeah yeah that guy forget it
yeah yeah maybe not [ __ ] around with
financial crimes and you don't did you
know Gabe Sanchez did you know that one
of the biggest credit card frauds in the
entire country was
Trump's campaign did you know that yeah
yeah yeah I remember that's crazy that's
crazy oh in the video the video I made
was uh when I when I made it when I
launched it it was 11 15. so when I
wrote it was probably like
11
like probably a few days before that so
November November 12 2020 is when I
wrote it and then 11 15 2020 is when I
made the video that was calling out
election uh Trump's election defense
fund well and the crazy part because if
you go back and you look at the clips
because you just took clips from that
current period and it's Clips like
people at Maricopa County and they're
[ __ ] praying and all kinds just crazy
ass [ __ ] oh oh that one I thought you
were talking about the election defense
fund where he was asking about money no
you're talking about the one that we
play on the show yeah the Trump fund
that we play on the show yeah yeah yeah
yeah that one that was back yeah it was
probably around the same time actually
right right because because that one
that we play on the show where it's a
commercial the parody commercial that
one's [ __ ] it's uh fantastic and
that's why I keep playing the same ones
is because they're completely [ __ ]
relevant
um and they I don't know how long
they'll be but Jesus Christ this is
getting ridiculous uh let's see uh oh
yeah the fake collector scheme and then
also the very ending here it demands
documents about funding of the ellipse
rally that would include Genie Thomas
this is massive um in the Washington
Post has the story here so go go to
Allison's thread here and let me let me
give her some credit here uh oh nope
that's not the one I want
jeez Louise
push the wrong button God damn very good
thank you it's awesome this thread is
awesome you should go read the thread if
you can
um go read The Washington Post article
and you might be able to find a um uh uh
a gate-free link somewhere after this
because I think and everyone's saying
that there might be extensions for yeah
some browsers to bypass a paywall but
yeah something like that not everyone
can pay for these subscriptions so I get
it so if you want to go read the story
but definitely read uh Allison's thread
here and and follow Allison yeah and
keep her on your notes notifications I
got her on my notifications
um I definitely check in to Allison's
Twitter account every day for some of
these updates I think she's in DC now
I'm really
um like she's working yeah I think so I
think so uh if I get around we'll ask
her that stuff yeah I really I really
wanted to uh have her explain this
thread of why these things are important
um so if we can have her on we'll
definitely get her on but um I don't
know it feels like it feels like Abe
Sanchez
that the Biden special counsel is going
to come to a very quick end uh yeah with
a quick conclusions and I'm sure
Republicans will be like oh and you guys
rush through
her is a deep stator now who knows yeah
that's what it'll be
exactly and also I just want to point
something out so I tweeted something
after the mayor Garland uh announcement
came out and I see people who are like
uh
Merit needs to go mayor Garland spent
too much time [ __ ] [ __ ] what I will
tell you right now is
there's uh one you know obviously
there's a I think there's a difference
in terms of the the uh the intensity of
what's Happening Here Right what
president Trump did and the Very like
you've got to go around like here's
President Biden isn't showing this [ __ ]
off to people right he's not bragging
about it he doesn't have crazy
classified nuclear documents he's not
making false accusations right the
reason that it took so long is because
again you want to be very careful right
as you as you obviously it's a very
political moment it's a politicized
moment and you want to be sure about
what's going on and then obviously if
you look at what's going on right now
you're like well President Biden isn't
[ __ ] showing this [ __ ] off he's not
showing this to this person he's not
taking documents he's not asking to
review stuff he's actually doing his job
as president and so the idea that
Republicans want to complain and say oh
we need a special counsel okay fine you
can have your special counsel we'll do
it even quicker because we had an
initial investigation and what we
discovered was very small and what you
want to show here is that yeah we'll
play games man we'll play the [ __ ]
game that you want to play which is if
we get a special counsel you get one so
when people say oh mayor Garland needs
to go dude he's he's okay one he's doing
his job and he's assigning the people
that need to look into it and he's also
focusing on the more important matters
while independent people that cannot be
touched cannot be touched by the House
of Representatives as much as the
Republicans want to defund these
operations they can't independent
silos okay the House of Representatives
cannot get access to their [ __ ] and they
cannot shut them down
so
they got what they got we got what we
got it's going to show that this is a
clear apples to oranges situation this
is not one of the same right they are
they are around a similar topic but the
amount of [ __ ] that that uh that Trump
has stepped in versus Biden is very
different okay very very different here
and so when people say uh
mayor Garland's got to go and he was too
slow and do this it's almost as if it's
almost as if I don't know what the was
that important no this was not no it was
not in the presentation of Tony
but the idea if you want to complain
about it I just I'm look don't follow me
I don't [ __ ] care you can shut the
[ __ ] up right because really honestly
you know I I agree with you stop if
you're not understanding what Merrick
Garland's job is and how he's supposed
to operate fine whatever if you just
want to [ __ ] and yell and scream at
Clouds like these other [ __ ] idiots
fine whatever do your thing I'm telling
you telling you right now
that if there is a case to be made
whoever it is Trump Eastman Clark
whoever the [ __ ] it is if there's a case
to be made and they have the evidence in
front of a grand jury they will indict
they will
and especially especially when Trump is
the person that literally and we saw it
during this summer literally was the
person nobody wanted to touch Eastman
nobody wanted to touch him because he
was so [ __ ] crazy with his ideas
he called and Trump called RNC chair
Ronald McDaniel got her on the phone and
then said hey I also got Eastman on the
phone you guys should talk
and then that literally he was the
literal connection okay so I'm I'm
almost certain that that point is going
to be amazing a main legal uh point that
they're making in in this investigation
to show that Trump wasn't just like
sending people to go do stuff he
literally was calling one person and
then party lining the other person to
bring them on it was like hold on gotta
add the caller and then brought in
Eastman and then Ronald McDonald oh [ __ ]
what the uh uh okay fine and then
Eastman of course was like look we want
to support you guys so this is what you
guys needed to support us
it's gonna [ __ ] bite them in the ass
right right it's gonna come back and get
them and look I know a lot of people in
the chat are like they're not gonna
serve a day and all that [ __ ] look I I
understand your frustration here but
look at it through the lens of politics
and elections folks if that's what you
got to do to make yourself feel all good
about it
because the fact of the matter remains
is that you're not going to appoint a
special counsel for the January 6 and
the documents case at Mar-A-Lago which
they're one in the same and we know the
evidence even even the select committee
was like look we don't have to refer him
for crimes but we're going to yeah we're
going to
now look through it through the prism of
Elections right we're not in election
cycle yet they think we are people think
we are we feel like we are because this
is a stupid thing we do in this country
now is where every [ __ ] election
cycle is two years long it's ridiculous
that as soon as as soon as everyone is
sworn in ah the next election starts but
that is what they want this is what they
do because they politicize everything so
look at that through the lens of
politicization right what is going to be
better going into this real election
cycle and what I mean by that is
sometime at the in the summer the fall
here
and Donald Trump and his allies are
being indicted and Joe Biden's special
counsel is like yeah here's the facts
here's what happened here you go here's
all the [ __ ] hey it's a nothing Burger I
mean literally I mean they are going to
serve you up on a platter all that we
need just like they did with Roe just
like they did that just like they did
with the January 6th narrative just like
they did with stop the steal and the big
lie they're going to continue to hand
you the narrative that we need so yeah
uh you know what if he doesn't serve a
day in prison as long as I can use the
the facts at hand to politicize this and
make sure to crush them politically so
they don't steal our democracy you know
am I going to be upset the [ __ ]
doesn't serve prison time yeah sure
whatever
I just don't want him him or any of them
like him like they do now on our House
of Representatives have their [ __ ]
grubby little vile fascist hands on our
democracy because they want to destroy
it want destroy it
so keep that in mind that this isn't
just about Merrick Garland this isn't
just about Jack Smith or even Donald
Trump it's about them wanting to take
control of our [ __ ] democracy and
tear it down
tear it down and get rid of it and it's
your democracy it's your democracy and
you should want to fight for it and one
way to fight for it is to subscribe here
at the Johnny Michaels podcast listen to
our narrative our messaging every single
weekday Monday through Friday noon
Eastern 11 Central 9 Pacific on YouTube
Twitter and twitch we're gonna get to 20
000 gauge Sanchez you give 20 000. we're
gonna get the 20 000 subscribers help us
in our efforts subscribe two years of
Tony uh we're close to our two-year
anniversary here two years January 14th
uh glass will go download every single
episode two days to the two year
anniversary yeah two days to the two
years of Tony Jesus Christ and get us to
20. all the Tet twos uh also follow us
on Twitter it's Thursday isn't it yeah
it's Thursday at Tony Michaels I think
we know who's gonna win bone net of the
week yeah yeah oh really I think I mean
hey you know
if I was a betting man okay well I would
say that maybe so you got an idea who
the three are gonna be and who the three
are going to be I don't know yet all
three okay I'm thinking about all three
but I I think one of the three I think I
pretty sure he's gonna win everyone pay
attention to to Twitter at Tony Michaels
but go follow us there and you can also
vote for bone end of the week on YouTube
so be watching for that poll because
tomorrow in the second hour of the Tony
Michaels podcast we will break down the
bone in the week Poll for you our
audience because you vote you decide we
break it down for you every single
Friday
and with that we're running that time so
tomorrow's Friday same time same place
you [ __ ]
Surfs Up [ __ ]
you've been listening to the Tony
Michaels podcast in your face commentary
of current events and political news no
rules No Boundaries I think we've made
that perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed
the show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ]
them
[Music]
Murphy's muleborn headass Beacon